all right y'all let's check in with a
great story from social media this is
what I'm
liking so some of you may know Montana
is my second home because I never shut
up about it um I've fallen in love with
the state I love it so much um as well
as the incredible people who live there
recently I learned about a publication
called the Montana woman magazine it's
entirely staffed by women uh from the
writing to the design to the photography
we have the owner and publisher with us
say hello to Megan who watches on kpax
TV in Missoula what's
[Applause]
up I I love Missoula by the way college
towns are always so fun but welcome to
the show Megan uh what stories do you do
like what do you love to cover thank you
uh we cover women across Montana so it's
a Statewide magazine so I always say
it's any woman anywhere in Montana doing
anything so we've had entrepreneurs
business owners Artisans makers we've
had a sustainable butcher a moccasin
maker a massage therapist it's anyone
anywhere in Montana doing anything we
have poetry General articles It's A
Slice of Life at Montana it's incred
I've literally I've said this before in
the show the women in that state they're
incredible so you you took over the
magazine four years ago right yes I
bought the magazine when I was 24 so the
magazine had been in print for 25 years
the previous owner was stepping down and
I saw the opport to make it what it
could have been because I had so much
potential and I bought it I knew nothing
about print or business publishing
nothing uh so I learned along the way
and it's been amazing it's such an honor
and a privilege to be able to share
these stories within Montana but also we
have subscribers across 42 States so
their stories get out Coast to Coast as
well um which is again such a privilege
to be able to share these incredible
women on a national platform yeah and
I'm glad you're doing it I just I don't
even know how to put into words but
they're just so well-rounded like
everyone does everything like these
heroin characters that you've you know
read in like you know in janire or in
like any like literature they actually
live there like they're actually
conquering everything gardening welding
fixing their fence building their house
doing their renovating their kitchen
like doing all the things hunting
they're doing all the things it's it's
just incredible to me I didn't grow up
around women that did anything like that
so an incredible thing I'm glad you're
covering them thank you for joining us
yeah thank you for having me and helping
share their stories as well absolutely
all right well thank you to Megan and
I'm liking her post right now but that's
not all our season long partner pilot
pin makers of G2 the go-to pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show want to honor truly
Unstoppable people just like you and the
women of Montana so they are going to be
writing you a check for $1,000 just for
fun thank you so much thank you so much
Megan maybe I'll see you in Miss
thank you to all our guests this hour
Jamie Lee Curtis Allison hord boss and
black Pumas y have a great day and if
it's not TR
[Applause]
[Music]
changes thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home